so I guess I'm gonna start with the most
important thing the film was made in
Massachusetts you - yep so is it true or
not true that you worked for Duncan
giftcards Hey well I mean I would have
if they only knew sorry if you're from
New England you grew up with Dunkin
Donuts yeah and so it's a whole coffee
thing Donuts - do you ever get free
donuts let me know jumping in - why I
actually get to talk to you guys today
let me start by saying congratulations
the movie is is fantastic I'm sure it's
a love fest from every single person
walking in scripts like this don't come
along that often what was it like for
the two of you reading it for the first
time and were you able to put it
together or were you sort of like it was
only at the very end for me it was only
at the very end I thought I knew who it
was but no I was wrong it was just
really surprising like it was misleading
me all the way through and I thought it
was an English language barrier but it
was not it's just how you know I'm
predictably was big surprise yeah yeah
same I mean it's that's what made the
script so enjoyable not only is it a
page-turner because it's very plot heavy
and there's a constant engine driving it
but but I there was a lot of times I
thought I know what's gonna happen I
know who did this and and then it keeps
making these twists and turns and that's
how you know this movie's gonna it's
gonna service the audience really well
yeah did you guys know when you were
making it how funny it was because every
I've seen it twice and both times it
erupts the theater mm-hmm
I mean I didn't think I was funny when I
was doing it yeah then maybe I think I'm
a little funny no he's right but me
watching them doing what they do so
brilliantly I just had the best time as
a as a just an observer as an observer
like seeing them like going crazy those
family scenes it was awesome yeah I knew
before I signed on that some of the
actors that were attached so I was able
to read the script with the first time
with
in mind and it certainly made the the
the experience more enjoyable and and
they absolutely delivered on the day you
know um one its it yeah can only imagine
Oh actually I want to ask a different
question of the two of you Ryan said
that the shot the one that took the most
takes was you two in the car because you
had the giggles when you were driving
what did I do
I feel like when you were when you were
doing your work yes probably yeah maybe
yeah it was a it was just funny they
know you were you were with me who was
laughing I can't you say it was a scene
of you two in the car together you got
the giggles and he said it took a little
while yeah probably
yeah I was looking for more but that's
okay I just really don't remember
I remember I mean I couldn't even I
couldn't I mean I I I know I know what
scene is I just don't know what we were
in laughs in fact I don't know I'll
leave it there and just say I already
got to go
I miss you wasting your I know I thought